sto gioco è una merda ma ma dobbiamo far
valere le nostre abilità di disegno
perché se no non sono contento quindi
cominciamo dai dati ragazzi venuti
questo video sono fa vj oggi siamo su
qui credo vi ricordiate ormai tutti di
questo splendido gioco perché è andato
su per bene l'ultima volta quindi hanno
capito tutti che in realtà sono un
picasso che non ha mai smesso di sognare
consiste per chi non lo conoscesse nel
disegnare entro venti secondi la cosa
qua descritta è una volta disegnano un
attimo sto stavo spiegando comunque c'è
una tipa che tenta di indovinare allora
devo disegnare del pane esatto esatto
perché quello è un pane porca [ __ ]
cruise ship quindi la barca di tom
cruise avremo riuscire a far la barca di
ton
non so se mi aspetto il massimo ma come
fai a aspetta questo remo che sanremo
dai zia è facile qui c'è il mare dai
frate mi ha indovinato pane che era la
cosa più merdosa questa che l'ho fatta
benissimo cazzo picasso mancato layers
mark players d'origine ma il play ha
prima tom cruise poi mar players players
players le pinze l'imac player vuol dire
mark pinza proviamo a disegnare delle
pinze fatte bene tipo queste vai ai
titans fantastico per non sarò mai fatto
indovinare ma va bene così cartolina
cartolina ci riesco a questa una cosa
semplice grazie di dio ai si trova
decenni ora die ziet facile ma che
pasport qua c'è una casa c'è una casa
tutta bella che vede bel posto ma
[ __ ] uragano a questo non so fare
ragazzo semplicissimo brava chiariamo un
paio di cose
indovini pane indovini pinze indovini
uragano e non mi indovini cartolina
porca [ __ ] facilissimo lollipop
partenza 1 su 6 da che già possiamo fare
ragazzi l'obiettivo e 6 su 6 e fin qua
atac
ecco disegnare le anatre non è proprio
il mio appunto
il migliore un attimo dai bellissimi e
bellissima da zia ai siti è bellissima
anche problemi c'hai nella mia vita non
insegnerò mai più una cazzo di papera
migliore di questa ma mai più traffic
light sarebbe luce il lyxor lire al
semaforo semaforo a fermi un attimo
bravissimo dei quattro su sei ci siamo
già stiamo facendo lega 46 dei main
momento della vita ragazzi il rainbow
posso cambiare colore non possono
mescolare va bene e prima parcheggi
brava brava mi chiamo altera difficile
questo paperclip che stefano sia una
clip semplicemente non voglio di una
cagata perfetto anche su capace in
perfetto 6 su 6 al secondo tentavi sa
che va veloce picasso può accompagnare
sodo è picasso look ragazzi faccio uno
screen e lo condivido su twitter perché
voglio vedere che cosa mi risponde alla
gente subito per questa cosa solo per
vedere che cosa dite solo per curiosità
per carità di dio meglio di me
sicuramente van gogh possono
accompagnare l'artista dell'anno
dell'anno grazie grazie che apprezzate e
bellissimo che chiedere il parere alla
gente in diretta bellissimo canguro
partiamo con la prima il lavoro fatto
anche l'altra volta mi fare però non
solo un attimo un attimo dal giglio si
capisce che un canguro dai film si
capisce sai mai con chi sa se fa niente
elefante elefante l'elefante quindi
disegno due bottiglie di fanta una barca
è triste che era mano a volte quante
storta sta roba
la proboscide the great wall of china
zia guarda sia stata fenomenale come mai
indovinato no non ho capito non ho
prestato attenzione non ho capito se
indovinato stop sign
e grazie al cazzo se non se lo
scrivevano indovinare i cavi dei
problemi di lettura con tenendovi nato e
stavolta 23 di tre bellissimo che guarda
l'elefante quant'è bello altre opere dal
louvre arte contemporanea hai sbagliato
mestiere ma guarda lo penso anch'io zia
poor's che c'è una borsa più brava zia
brava vedi che le bolle tipo e le borse
lei con su subito chabod l'occhio poteva
anche disegnare john travolta ma
sicuramente avrebbe detto borsa sega è
qua dipende da che punto di vista la
intendi però facciamo quella normale
quella che possono mettere sui facciamo
quella che posso mettere su youtube
fantastico leg gamba va bene visto
sbagliato non lo fermi cos'era sta roba
che office dic
anzi anche un piede sembrava più il
piede del big foot ma va bene l'ultima
ragazzi di un 6 su 6 vaso evaso bass in
queste sicuri e non sono sicuro basso ok
poi si capisce che un passo dai si
capisce idiota dams capisce che un base
ma più in appena schiacciata dai cara 5
su 6 5 su 6 [ __ ] perché non mi
indovina vaso ma dai streetlight 16
streetline quanto diventa difficile
lampione
brava string bean che è un parente di
mister bean string b mica fagiolo e mi
faceva porca [ __ ] piselli piselli sarei
ai canti a set
neanche una neanche mezza anima
immigration che non sia quella degli
uccelli
io come fottutamente la disegno questa
merda cinque gli uccelli che volano via
t non fate domande perché vedere l'area
action del pubblico anche a questo cosa
intendevi trasmettere con questo schizzo
sopraffino giuro che a me non sembra
proprio una barca non fare domande e
giulia dovresti venderli faresti
miliardi guarda ci penso su ma quanto
siamo raccomandati noi di twitter che
abbiamo gli spoiler per il video mi
chiaramente animal migrations paga più
del canguro di prima di segnare le punte
blu di what's up tutorial vai fa vigeva
dei ragazzi facciamo l'ultima che ormai
credo che non abbiamo tutti abbastanza
delle mie capacità
play again proviamo l'ultima circle
uguale se non indovina di questa
potevano ricoverarmi a me mi
ricoveravano a me al manicomio per le
testate che tiravo al monitor sun
quante soddisfazioni da questa donna
quante me ne da madonna che orgasmo
occhio tutte le cose tonde mi stai
chiedendo tutte tutte cose più ovale un
occhio orcaella mi piace ai problemi e
teschio tutte e tonde tutte così tonde e
il teschio yes yes 4 su 6 porca eva
questo siamo veloci face
tutte cose uguali mi sta chiedendo lo so
perché facebook così perché trovi un
forno quanto disegno un forno bravissima
vinca sorrisi nando il pollo 6 su 6 de
donnas signori che donne vabbè ragazzini
o anche oggi dato prova di capacità
artistiche l'ho fatto anche vedere su
twitter quindi grazie di avere assistito
a queste opere d'arte ricordatevi che
adesso parte l'asta su ebay
cinquemila euro a pezzo li firmo io
fossi in voi e mi affretterei perché tra
un po queste cose valgono ragazzine
spero che vi sia piaciuto cose che mi è
piaciuto il momento è un mi piace anche
ai vari social che come di
sottoscrizione federici di semplici che
diamo al prossimo video da ragazzi